hi my name is john
of john bear woodworks located in winder
pennsylvania
i restore antiques and furniture
today i am restoring this three mirror
1950s vanity
since i knew that this piece had been
painted over with several coats of paint
i was just really excited to see what
was hidden under there
i start by applying a gel stripper and i
apply that with a brush
and i like to really glob it on you got
to get it on thick
and then let it sit it can't be dry it
has to stay wet
so it's working and then once you let
that sit for 15-20 minutes you can
really start scraping and finding out
what you have hiding underneath your
projects
i like to use just this regular
run-of-the-mill putty knife
i round the edges on a little bit so i
don't have any sharp edges that will
gouge the furniture
and always just take special care use
light pressure
not to gouge scratch it anymore
as those chemicals in the stripper sit
on top of that
finish whatever you're stripping it just
liquefies
that finish and leaves you with this
sludge
i typically scrape it right into a metal
you know
old paint can
a tip i got one time from an old timer i
used to work with
is this sawdust trick when i apply the
sawdust
it soaks up all that stripper and you're
not left with all that gooey mess
on there that you need to wipe off or
anything
as i'm using this technique you want to
make sure that you go
with the grain just like you would with
sanding or scraping or anything you
don't want to go against that grain or
light pressure you don't want to cause
any scratches or gouges to the wood
i'm sanding to remove any of the
remaining residue or the scratches that
might be in that wood
and you'll really know if there is
anything left
when you go to apply the stain i usually
start sanding
most any type of wood with a 150 it's a
pretty common grit
and then i finish it up with a 220 grit
and this will help to remove any more of
the scratches
that might have been in the wood and
make it really smooth especially like
any type of maple or really dense wood
is more likely to hold scratches
next i will just use an iron and a wet
rag
on the wood surface to remove any of the
scratches or dings
i will just move on to some final odds
and ends and steps that i
take to just do some final touch-ups
removing the scratches
removing any of the last finish that
might be remaining before i do that one
last final sanding before staining
i will use an oil-based stain that i
mixed this color to my preference
and i like this reddish tint i feel like
it really brings out that bird's eye you
know maple a lot more
i typically will tell people when i'm
working on a piece
the red mahogany tends to look a little
bit more elegant
or refined once the stain has had a
chance to set up and dry for a couple
days
i apply this seal coat of lacquer
before i sand that and apply the final
top coat
it's always nice to see these pieces
come back to life for a second life
instead of ending up in the dump or out
to a curbside
and i just really enjoy this work and
brings me happiness and it's good to see
that it makes other
people happy
[Music]
he's my handy helper
[Music]
you